hallo leute ich es wieder eure x plane
und fast eine woche später kann ich euch
schon zum nächsten sommer noch begrüßen
wie kommt's berlin haben hier nicht
regelmäßig den schweiß von der stirn
tupfen denken die leute ich hab zu viel
highlighter benutzt oder so mein
lieblings netzfilter ist diese woche
dieses eine pokemon ich glaube das ist
saxo mir auf mit diesem quatsch denn es
gibt jetzt geschichten aus der youtube
wäldern mag es kaum glauben doch mit
thema für diese woche ist weit
nach der trennung von heute die haben
sich die mitglieder philippe petit und
mit ihrem eigenen geschäft so hat es zum
beispiel eine agentur gegründet am
spyder in der mark mode über zusammen
bringen wenn man zb als schauspieler bei
dem film bibi und tina wo ich echt sagen
muss dass er richtig gut und solche
teeniefilm rheinfalls also den jungs
gegen mädchen habe ich ihn wirklich
abgekauft jungs gegen mädchen ein
mädchen gegen jungs jungs gegen mädchen
ein mädchen gegen jungs also props an
den songwriter nur von pc hat man nicht
so viel gehört
bis jetzt denn hat auf seinem eigenen
kanal ein video hochgeladen er sagt dass
es wieder mit youtube losgehen soll also
ich finde das video jetzt so lala
deswegen für eine bewertung ala denn ich
werde mich das gefühl los dass er bei
diesem album war teddy humor bleiben
möchte
das war aber weiter denn jetzt wo er nur
noch tee ist würde ich nicht raten sein
eigenes ding zu machen und dann klappt's
auch mit der solo karriere wurde er
fragt das internet also tc zuerst packs
sowie einen packung nudeln auf deinen
kopf nächste kategorie bekommen wie zu
meinen hengst
mein lieblings um diese woche ist nine
million bicycles von kate moss ich
bekomme jedes mal für stunden einen
ordnung wenn ich dieses lied hört zu
anderen ist es immer noch nach so vielen
jahren so schön den song zu hören und
man kommt immer so schön grund und zu
guter letzt ist das musikvideo einfach
supercool ich frag mich jedes mal wieder
wie die das gemacht haben
ich hab eine ungefähre vorstellung aber
es ist und bleibt ein rätsel
und ich frage mich wie schmutz hier
oberteil danach war kommen wir zum
wetter am südpol in der nacht wird es
diese woche bis zu minus 55 grad kalt
und ab und zu kommen paar wolken sonne
als es ist ziemlich wechselhaft
damit waren auf jeden fall den kamin
anschmeißen fakt ist die kälteste
gemessene temperatur wurde auf der
russischen station rostock gemessen und
zwar - 89 2 grad celsius fit ist
ziemlich kalt das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von einer spitzen denn
vanessa persönliche austausch soll es so
warm es tut mir die hwz ausziehen besser
es ist komisch ist man hose wieder kurse
wieder an
ich kann euch nicht länger auf die
folter denn jetzt gibt es meine
favoriten mein erster favorit wie könnte
es anders sein ist pokémon gott seid ich
mir diese etwa einer geholt habe war ich
glaube ich jeden abend draußen für zwei
stunden um pokémon zusammen so viel war
ich glaube ich im ganzen letzten jahr
nicht spazieren und nicht nur das wir
spazieren gehen und pokémon spielen wir
gehen auch das wasser in restaurant und
machen uns darauf module an und sitzen
denn da wie das bescheuerte pärchen der
welt
ich habe wirklich alle lustige puppen
und ghost eines tages geht raus um einen
tour zurück zu suchen was mir da auf der
karte angezeigt wird lässt ich hab mir
jungen gegen der ganz panisch auf mich
schaut und fragt suchst du auch das tut
nichts ja ja ja ja ja ja sagt jörg komm
mit ich weiß wie es ist ich laufe
natürlich mit dann bleiben wir stehen
und fallen dieses tool talk in der zeit
kommen zehn leute um gelungen auffahren
ein angerannt um alle dieses album easy
to shop fahren und ich denke da war so
mein gott ich habe mit vier neue leute
kennengelernt so fremde von der straße
juli was mich allerdings merkte dass ich
für den pokémon trainer club angemeldet
bin und der server stürzt öfter auf
dafür war mein start up pokémon aber ein
pikachu und ich bin schon der bild 12
merkels nicht verziehen
mein favorit ist diese woche ganz klar
der youtube kanal sowie journal dieser
typ macht mich einfach fertig sein humor
so speziell und ich muss ihm passt so
krass lachen und bei der pitti szene bin
ich echt gestorben also schaut auf jeden
fall bei dem youtube kanal sowie ist
lange vorbei denn ich glaube der hat
schon mehr abos verdient kommen jetzt
meinen top 3 zu wollen
dabei geht mit ihm die nötige
hintergrundstory der super hängt sondern
mit wenig gern zusammen sein würde
auf platz 30 bis pakistan auf platz 2
gehört für mich mein reynolds und für
bin ich jetzt ende der welt fliegen
würde natürlich für chris hemsworth thor
chris hemsworth chris henry brett kommen
nur zur trainerfrage
ich habe euch auf twitter gefragt
welches pokémon hättet ihr gerne als
haustier und warum und das sind eure
antworten mein körper dort das würde
mich jeden tag daran erinnern dass es
menschen gibt die noch weniger können
sich an timos weil es den haushalt
machen würde wie man ihm ihr mandant nur
einfach weil drache carlito weil es sich
zu jedem anderen pokémon verwandeln kann
was sind das denn für haus die
qualitäten ganz einfach die katze dann
mit einer unendlichen power bänke
pokémon go spielen das ist sehr schlau
aber wenn du pokemon hast warum bis zu
einer pokémon go spielen auch ein entern
denn es sind niedlich ganz klare lachs o
mat ist immer dabei pikachu weil man
dann keine stromrechnung mehr bezahlen
muss und es ist ganz scheint auch sie
nicht ich hoffe hier diese folge summe
aufgefallen und das nächste mal wird
sich nicht so doll
ich verspreche ich